the saints row series is back and
looking to reinvent itself instead of
picking up where part 4 left off this
new entry is taking you back to the
beginning with an all-new cast of
characters causing mayhem in a brand new
city here's everything you need to know
about saints row
saints row is all about creating your
own criminal empire if you think that
sounds familiar you're right because
it's not too far off from the goal of
the original game however instead of
spreading your influence across
stillwater the new saints row is set in
the fictional city of santo eliso this
huge and vibrant sandbox is located in
the southwest united states and seems to
combine the vibes of life locations like
las vegas and albuquerque at the start
of the reboot you're a member of a
private military corporation and all you
want to do is make enough money to cover
your half of the rent however when
climbing the corporate ladder doesn't
quite work out you turn to climbing the
criminal ladder instead are we gonna
make rent we'll make rent we just gotta
be a little more creative
last time we got creative i got stabbed
three times hey it would have been four
times if nina and i hadn't shown up your
roommates slash literal partners in
crime consists of the business
mastermind eli who cares more about
making the money than how the money is
made the getaway driver nina who is a
member of the muscle car and exercise
obsessed los panteros as well as the
people pleaser kevin who is a member of
the anarchist nightclub owners known as
the idols with this opportunity to start
over series developer volition wanted to
create criminals that were more
relatable and one way of doing that is
to show them starting from nothing
another way is to include characters
that are struggling to pay back student
loans because what's more relatable than
that the team also thought it was
critical to introduce new characters due
to some major changes in saints row 4
which i won't spoil here but if you know
you know
[Music]
like previous games in the series saints
row features familiar third-person
shooter gameplay in order to expand your
criminal empire you'll be engaging in a
bunch of different activities including
main quests side quests as well as a new
activity called criminal ventures
another new addition to the saints row
formula comes in the form of more
options for vehicle combat from side
swiping your enemies to hopping on top
of the car and firing back as you surf
on it there are multiple new ways to
take on your foes while moving there's
also the addition of a wingsuit so you
can fly around the city for fun or eject
yourself from the car open your wingsuit
and escape in style and there's also
your typical video game stuff like
completing missions earns you experience
points that play into a leveling system
leveling up takes you along a linear
progression path earning either new
equippable skills or earning you passive
upgrades like boost to your overall
health the skills are the cool part as
you can assign them to a certain button
and use them in the heat of battle and
saints row also includes a variety of
gameplay challenges you can complete
while you're doing other things with
objectives like driving the oncoming
traffic lane for a certain amount of
time or shooting a certain number of
enemies in the head with a specific kind
of weapon completing these challenges
unlocks perks you can equip to your
character to further customize their
abilities slots to equip more perks
unlock as you spend the money you earn
in the game creating a whole system that
incentivizes you to mess around with
saints row and engage with its various
aspects while adding new ways to deck
out your character according to your
playstyle with the game's new in-depth
character creator you'll be able to
change nearly everything about your boss
of course there are tons of clothing
options as well as the return of layered
clothing but in saints row you'll also
be able to customize your skin down to
details like texture glossiness color
veins scars tans body hair etc you can
also change the features of your entire
face and make it asymmetrical a new
addition to the series for a very
memorable look and the deep
customization doesn't stop at your
character's body there are also a lot of
ways to personalize the game's vehicles
and weapons as well
like previous games in the series saints
row will feature drop in dropout
cooperative online multiplayer allowing
for you and one other friend to team up
and play together completing missions
while in co-op will transfer over to
your own save so you won't waste time or
lose your boss's character progression
by playing in someone else's game so if
you've just started but you play a late
game mission with a buddy the game will
remember that and won't force you to
play that mission again once you reach
it in your own save
volition plans on releasing three
post-launch expansions for saints row
all of which will be included in the
game's expansion pass they haven't
revealed details about the packs just
yet but we're sure they're filled with
mayhem make sure to subscribe to
gamespot so you can get the details when
they're announced
[Music]
similar to the rest of the series saints
row is being developed by volition and
published by deep silver in an interview
chief creative officer jim boon
mentioned the team abolition used a
handful of action films as reference for
the reboot films like baby driver for
its vehicular movement hobbs and shaw
for its extravagance and john wick for
its stylized combat jim added that
today's social climate has outgrown the
tone of prior saints row games aka
moving away from sex toys as weapons was
a bit of a needed change
saints row will be released on ps4 ps5
xbox series xns xbox one and pc via the
epic game store
saints row was scheduled to launch on
august 23 2022 the game was originally
set to release on february 25th before
being delayed so that the team could do
a little bit more fine-tuning it's
available for pre-order both through the
game's official website and select
online retailers there are three
physical additions to the game standard
for 60 dollars chrono customs for sixty
dollars and notorious for ninety dollars
there are also three digital editions of
the game standard for sixty dollars gold
for ninety and platinum for one hundred
all six editions have the idols anarchy
pack as a pre-order bonus but you'll
also get the saints criminal customs
pack for pre-ordering the criminal
customs notorious gold or platinum
editions the physical criminal customs
edition adds the saints criminal customs
pack so it's basically just an addition
designed to give you an extra bonus for
pre-ordering the game so since it costs
the same as the standard edition you
might as well nab the criminal customs
edition if you're planning on
pre-ordering finally the notorious
edition adds the expansion pass and
comes with physical collectibles
including a steelbook case like the
physical version the digital version of
the standard edition only comes with the
base game the gold edition adds the los
panteros american muscle bundle and the
expansion pass while the platinum
edition includes all of that plus a
digital copy of saints row the third
remastered
so let's recap the new saints row
features new characters a new city
deeper customization new vehicle combat
a wingsuit and loads of ways to cause
chaos as you rise to the top of the
criminal food chain that's everything
you need to know about saints row hit
the comment section and let us know if
you plan on playing the game when it
releases and if you've pre-ordered which
one did you get make sure to subscribe
to gamespot so you don't miss out on any
new updates as well as our saints row
review when it's available you can find
me on social media at devonta chisholm
thanks for watching
[Music]
[Music]
you